your book subtitle is a warning to save
democracy from the next Trump there are
people who think that Trump is singular
uh that Trump is Trump we survive 2024
where Trump dies and then we are okay
and it seems like you have a different
take it's a much more significant
phenomenon than that and I'll confess to
Andrew to have having been naive about
this myself is I went into the
administration originally viewing Trump
as an apparition as a phenomenon of
someone of deficient moral character who
once he was gone from office would
essentially be replaced Again by more
rational Republicans and as you well
know uh you and I met while I was in the
middle of the fight after the Trump
Administration trying to get the
Republican party to swing the pendulum
back to the center and I will say we
failed miserably as those of us you know
in fact after the administration ended
me and a friend Evan McMullen who ran
for Senate as an independent in Utah
after the Trump Administration ended we
pulled together about 10 and president
as an independent and the president
2016. that's right Evan and I pulled
together uh about 200 Republicans you
know cabinet secretaries and congressmen
and Senators to have a conversation
about trying to go defeat Maga
candidates and again swing the pendulum
back to the center and I'll say after
two years of working in that space we
lost and we lost miserably because the
Maga wing of the party really took over
not just at the federal level but all
the way down to the state level and the
state parties but it at the same time if
you look at the data we saw the base
itself really transform and this is why
I worry about the next Trump and someone
trying to be a copycat is because they
will have to cater to the GOP base and
it's a GOP base that's become more
reactionary than it used to be what am I
talking about I'll drill into three
specific numbers a majority of
Republicans believe the election was
stolen from Donald Trump they believed
the big lie a majority of Republicans
today believe in the core tenets of Q
Anon the Q Anon conspiracy theory that a
cabal of deep State operatives secretly
run the government and a slight majority
of Republicans believe in the great
replacement theory that secretly
Democrats are trying to infiltrate
people of color into the United States
to replace whites now that was not the
case 10 years ago a majority of the
Republican Party didn't hold those sort
of conspiracy theory views but now that
they do anyone who wants to win that
nomination has to cater to that base and
so I worry about even if it's not Donald
Trump that a successor will carry
forward a lot of those policies and
we're already seeing it I'll give you
two examples Andrew of policies that
even trumped himself decided not to
pursue that now his alkaline lights are
pursuing one would be this idea of
bussing and dumping migrants in
Democratic cities so when I was in the
administration we got a phone call from
the president and he wanted us to in his
words send murders rapists and criminals
that had been arrested at the border and
bust them into Democratic cities to
cause chaos and disorder and then to
send other migrants in his political
pawns to overflow Social Services well I
went back to the lawyers obviously doing
that was deemed illegal right it was
illegal to try to use these people as
pawns and to ship them around the
country well since his presidency and he
was talked out of it he ultimately stood
down since his presidency we've seen
people like Ron DeSantis in Florida and
Greg Abbott in Texas actually pick up
that policy and pursue it they've gone
and they've stuck migrants on airplanes
flown them into different cities as
political pawns and continued that a
second policy Trump was talked out of uh
was as I mentioned earlier gutting the
FBI there was this notion that the FBI
should be cleansed of deep State
operatives and they should take a
wrecking ball to the institution Trump
was dissuaded from doing that because he
was told if he did that he would be
impeached yes he fired Jim Comey but he
stopped there uh and now you know what
was originally I think all of us thought
that was a fringe complaint that he
wanted to get rid of people at the FBI
and it was only because they were
investigating him now it's a leading
talking point of the Republican party
and people who are in Republican
leadership in the house and the
candidates on the field is that they
want to go detonate the FBI and replace
the institution so again two examples of
how the Maga movement has sort of grown
Beyond Donald Trump's control and taken
over the party and I think the
conditions are right for a savvier
successor to take over that movement and
potentially cause greater damage in
office so you have a very deep Network
among Republicans uh how many are in
that Fantasyland camp where they're like
look let's just like hunker down and
then after this this hurricane passes
then everything will quote come back to
normal and how many if you had to take a
guess if they get asked about things
like did Trump win or lose the election
they say something like oh you know you
can't know we should look into things
even though they know that he lost like
is there a proportion where you know
they're they're just speaking to the
base even though they know different
Andrew I would say it's probably a
majority of elected Republicans right
now I meet with these people all the
time I talk to them all the time some of
them are still my friends and privately
they will still say the same things they
were saying five years ago Donald
Trump's in aberration this will blow
over we just need to wait it out and
they've been proven wrong time and time
again and the best data point for that
is right now the man they told us would
go away is the leading candidate for the
GOP nomination at this moment and I
think that's the big concern
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang-up new
guest thank you